i wanted to connect israelis and jews in
the bay area and
for some reason or many reasons
in order to create trust among people
sometimes we need to do business because
business really creates some kind of
trust that otherwise you can't achieve
you can sit next to someone but you
wouldn't have the trust when you do
business with someone you need to have
trust otherwise you wouldn't do business
with
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hello stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders i am really
really excited and honored for this
episode because i get to have a
discussion with an amazing friend mentor
and colleague ordered hermony managing
partner of j ventures or that is an
investor entrepreneur and journalist
since 2005 he has invested in over 70
companies five of which became unicorns
as is currently the managing partner and
co-founder of the j ventures fund a
capitalist kibbutz in silicon valley
odette is active in philanthropic
organizations and has been a board
member at the jewish federation of san
francisco
jfcs friends of hebrew university icon
intro and more welcome my friend oded
welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you doing i'm doing great it's
behind you look behind us this is the
company look at the company oh dad i'm
so thankful to have you here uh we you
were one of the very first episodes i
did uh we've been together now for
almost two years
where you let me be a part of this
incredible journey called j ventures and
that i can't wait to dig deep into you
know the the complexity the
interpersonal internet interpersonality
of it and one of the most amazing vc
funds in the world uh objectively and
subjectively and
and i'm really really happy to be part
of it so thank you for bringing me along
but then before we even get to jay
ventures give me a little bit of round
down as to who who is you have a lot of
different
a lot of different personas i would say
who is the dead
i'll do it very very quick um
i was
all my life i was looking for something
that
from one side is doing things that are
good for the community the social side
the other side was the business side so
i started as a journalist it's a
business journalist was an editor
the market
scholar when i was 23 i think i started
editing
the
uh economy section of kolair we
established it and then i moved to arts
and then i moved to
the market i was the editor of the high
tech section and internet section
um and then
um
i wanted to move to the
to the business world
and i good i got a permission to start
my own startup
while i was still editing the the
hi-tech section
and i also looked for something that is
has some kind of an impact so
me and a childhood friend we created
something called dessert for you which
was a startup that
a connected
uh
cleaning ladies and babysitters and
mates with
with housekeep
with the house and the household because
they were in very different places in
israel so
a
cleaning lady from full on didn't know
the
the other people that lived just across
the street and we found jobs for about
15 000 people across the years wow and
people who couldn't find job otherwise i
mean we got letters from people i
remember
a couple who were both artists
playing music and they couldn't afford
computers for the kids and suddenly they
had 16 000
checkers net because they both worked
this is a cleaning and they wanted us we
bought two computers to our kids this
was the first purchase that was
important part wow so that was that part
and then i became a vc
when we sold this company to yellow
pages i had to move to to the other side
because and i i didn't use my even my
name i used a different name
uh and i didn't raise money for it
and then when we sold it i had to move
to um to the vc world i moved to the
dark side it became a
a part of capital point that we took
public and had also two accelerators one
in the north one in the south and for me
it was another mission of zionism how
you
bring um
the the peripheral of israel to become
part of the of the tech of the center we
had some crazy and very very uh
innovative companies over there in life
science in arctic and and some of them
did amazingly and huge exits the group
had one exit of one billion it was very
very interesting to see how you can
develop in the south and in the far
north of israel those kind of things
when you still have the office in azeri
and after that i
established a
what tend to be hka ieti it was hta and
before that ibi it all sounds like the
cia but this was the israeli venture
capital association that i didn't for
the tend to be hdia high-tech industry
association
and in 18 months we
from
in my perspective was
how you can leverage what we have inside
the ecosystem that was very not um very
fragmented you you had the
the multinational companies who didn't
know each other and the account academia
who didn't know the multinational and
the angels and it was like
the the engine of the israeli economy
but no one knew each other and of course
there were no ultra orthodox no woman uh
no alps and we wanted to bring everybody
in
and so we created um hga and then we
merge it with ilside that was the life
science into something that called a
iati which is now the largest umbrella
organization
and then
i decided to move to uh to silicon
valley
um i joined um
i joined the recognitive family daniel
ricci and iron my partner
and we had a fund called rhodium we
invested together
some great companies like kyoto outgreen
sawdust and and
other exits
and i was department in the u.s
and
um great people great companies and then
i
i moved to what i'm doing today okay so
the story of j ventures now it's it's
not just another traditional vc fund
that we see around the world this is a
very very special type of fund that is
able to do very very special things with
very special people and i want you to
take me back really to the founding
story and and how this starts from
inside of you because this is not just
another you know a place to make a lot
of money there there's a really personal
part to this
so so there were two parts of it the
first part was completely social i
wanted to connect israelis and jews in
the bay area and
for some reason or many reasons
in order to create trust among people
sometimes you need to do business
because business really creates some
kind of trust that otherwise you can't
achieve you can sit next to someone but
you wouldn't have the trust when you do
business with someone you need to have
trust otherwise you wouldn't do business
with us so this was how we started me
and jim jim costa and my partner
we started as an engine group we just
thought that this is the best way to get
people through the door and create a
community of israelis and jews and we
had 40 israelis 60 youth
in that group
and then it turned to be a vcc fund
after we saw
we had 16 individual investments and
five exits and it was very great it was
great
outcome
but people in the community saw that we
were missing great companies who said at
the end of the day this is the ninja
club with a lot of names
we want one name we want to see it
formalized so we created j ventures in
june 18th
three years ago
and
and it came from the people in the
community who said hey we see the the
quality of the deal flow let's have a
fun and i said guys i'm not interested
in having another passive
fund to manage for other people
i want to do something else
i want to be in a vc fund that first of
all
you invest not in companies who needs
you invest in companies who wants
and
and the second thing
i never thought that i'm the smartest
person in the world i thought that there
are so many other people who are smarter
than i am in every vertical why not
using them as a group
and make them active and involved not
just passive investors
so the limited partnership is still
limited partnership but the involvement
and engagement
that i wanted to see in my eyes
because at the end of the day i wanted
to create a community and if the
community just put the money then what's
the what's the community right but if
they are active and they're involved
then there's something new and i called
it the kibbutz said keyboard is a
limited partnership there's a lot of
people who are engaged and one time this
one is responsible for the cyber and the
other one responsible for the automotive
and the other one for the semiconductor
and each one is trusting the other one
to take the leadership when it's coming
to his own role
and from the company's perspective i
always looked at
there's a something so fluid called edit
event what is the edit then nobody
really knows what to get with it but if
you can really define anything and bring
specific mechanism of added value like
uh portfolio success that is you know
the logic behind portfolio success or
how you source how you screen
so this is
this is how i wanted to build j ventures
in a way that is different from all the
other vcs
i didn't believe that there
are great other vc but i want to create
a new model
in silicon valley in the heart of of of
the tech innovation and the heart of of
a of investments
that offers something else that is not
exist even in silicon valley
definitely not in israel
so we created it uh it's we are mostly
american jews i would say
not only we accept
people from different
backgrounds
and
we currently have this is the second
fund so the first one was was great the
second fund has uh around 350 investors
that
in general they're overlapping but in
general we have about 140
current and past lp gps in venture funds
almost all the top tier in u.s uh funds
many vcs also in israel but mostly in
u.s 140 is a lot it's great i don't know
any other vc fund that has so many
other
partners in vcs who invest in them and
to see other vcs putting their own money
for me it's a it's like it's the first
kosher step
the second culture stamp is that we have
about 100
um sale entrepreneurs ceos
um
who
and this is also interesting 12 of them
we invested in 35 companies over the
past three years so 12 of the 35
founders of our own portfolio are also
our lps so i think for me this was like
the biggest achievement
you see
an lp that starts his new company now
after he already saw this previous one
and he offers you to join in not because
he needs your money because you see the
benefit of this community that can help
him and he's always positive the other
side is that you invest in someone and
then he says listen i've never seen a
fund like this
can i join with nlp
so
that was very very important to see and
and the third part
is really the industry aspect there we
have
around 170 executives mostly vp to c
level in fortune 500
i think about 70 80 of them are sea
level currently or previously in
companies
a lot of power we can open those in
almost any
large company in the u.s
in any manner it's great and this helps
with design partners this helps with
markets this helps also because the
people who are
in those companies they are in those
roles that everybody goes to them anyway
they want to
they try to convince them to join so we
see all the different so we see about 20
2600 deals a year
that
90 percent of them are backed by vcs
and 40 percent of them
are very serious founders
and 50 of them are oversubscribed
so it enables us because of the
community to see a very unique kind of
things here
now one of the most amazing aspects of
jv interest is really the community
behind like you're mentioning over 350
lps that are that are behind this
massive community how is that how does
that how does it actually come to play
in the day-to-day because at the end of
fund has to meet founders
decided to make an investment and then
be part of the company you can't manage
350 people all coming and trying to help
this company at the same time right so
how does it actually happen tangibly you
know in the day-to-day
by the way when we come 350 it includes
sometimes the significant others
because sometimes they are more
interesting even than the so so people
come together we have by the way 12
brothers and 24 cousins but we have many
couples amazing and the couple so so
this is why it looks so so big
um
and you see that behind every successful
person there's even sometimes the most
successful person yeah that's fine so
how it works
um
and we try that it wouldn't be over
overwhelming for the entrepreneurs so
the first part is how we screen the
company so they come already from the
community so someone is pre-screening it
because he sends to us the best
companies that he can sell
either he comes from a big vc in the us
or he is a serial entrepreneur whatever
and then
we have a screening committee that
includes 20
plus uh former and current gps in bc
funds who see this the
distilled flow
and gives us input
and we have the same thing in life
science arctic and food tech
and
this is a massive um
knowledge in process
and then we we we end up
with um about 44 companies who present
to us
it's the whole kibbutz so you see about
170 people on the zoo meeting
and when you asked her about the
experience so he was the cfo of one of
the largest company he was the chief
general counsel of that company of
another company and he was a the
founding member of one of the the top
tbc
almost in every meeting we have enough
people who have
specific expertise in what the company
is doing and they give us the insight
so the companies present about 20
minutes
they get feedback and they get exposure
so almost all the companies whether
they've been backed by sequoia and
wrestling hobbies battery or whatever
all the big funds they come to present
to us because they want to have
a direct reach out to those people in
the crime
and
then we do a due diligence we vote
because this is still a group we call it
a minion if we have enough people then
we move forward and we move forward with
the due diligence process
and we pick from the experts in the
audience the right people who could
perform
the
the due diligence process
and this is
one of the best contacts of the the
company has because then they really get
beyond the group's feedback they get the
experts feedback and this is where this
engagement is is being established and
we
we move forward with them
and
even the companies that we decide not to
invest
they
they write to us after that thank you
for the process we learned a lot from
the posters we we
we stayed in touch with
xyz and they are helping us in their own
verticals
um so
it happened that we helped a lot of
companies with that we didn't invest in
but we have a significant added value to
the companies we do invest in so in some
companies we
like we have one portfolio company just
remembering now because they're raising
that has 1.2 million dollar air we we
are responsible for 300 000 out of it we
have a company that we open the markets
in latin america australia and new
zealand and central valley we have
another company that we bought
two vps to be in the in the
in the leadership
we have many companies that we have to
bring the other money from top tier vcs
in america that are part of j venture so
it's easier right uh a lot of design
partners
and what we've found that many of the
entrepreneurs who want us are not
necessarily first-time entrepreneurs
right the serial entrepreneurs can
appreciate more the added value they
understand the value now i want to go
back a little bit to the engagement of
the lps because this is really something
that's non-traditional if in a general
vc you would have the the analysts and
then the principal and then and the
partners really doing the massive due
diligence and and and coming up with the
convictions kiri still have a similar
process but the real magic happens when
you have these five or six experts
pulled in from over 300 experts in
various domains coming in wanting to
dedicate their time having fun with it
some of them don't necessarily even
invest in their day-to-day but they're
experts in this domain and they can come
in and not even thinking only about the
financial aspects but looking at the
technology looking at the work the the
world the thesis of this company they're
able to say things that no analysts can
ever come up with simply because they
have a virtue of 30 years of experience
in this field which is pretty remarkable
and it's also hard to pass them but the
value-added is is significant for
example
we we invest in a company that makes uh
virtual control tower so they use raf
for this purpose they just closed around
17 million
and
led by one of our investors by the way
for the due diligence process we bought
a former chief scientist of darpa
because it was relevant before the chief
former chief strategy officer of
blackberry
former gm of all the wireless of intel
uh former gm of of the aviation division
of styling
and and two others that are cto levels
in huge coffee i can't mention their
name unfortunately
because they're still active and we let
them meet with the company and they
spend about
this is the usual
uh due process is about 10 hours they
spend with the company and those people
are
no just one hour of them
worth more than they will invest in the
company
but um we ended up
the company was completely
oversubscribed
she asked for all of them to be advisors
one of them became and i was joining the
board
um
and
for him it was a significant added value
another company recently we invested was
in the gaming area and we bought svp and
zynga vp twitch uh senior director
riot games people from from other
companies in the spectrum
and
for example this company when the rest
were lots of great people but in in
funds but
they specified
who is behind j ventures for them to to
mention the titles was very important
for in the pr
so so that kind of things that really
brings value not just fluid kind of
thing and the second thing is we are
taking it very very
um very seriously we we built with your
help
it's very strong database of our
this is like our ip who was our a
community
and
we are able to take them to what we call
j advisory and to bring them to help the
company specifically and the company
choose so i'm thinking all the time when
i was a
in many years in the
industry companies had to to get
the board member from the vc who
invested in them not necessarily the
right person for the company but the
person who had the wallet right
and i wanted to create a win-win-win i
wanted
the right
board member the right advisor not
necessarily me
who will be joining the company because
the company wanted him they will get
compensation directly from the company
and this is where the win-win comes that
i know that someone of us is on the
board of that company always advising to
that company the entrepreneur is happy
he got the right person not because of
the money because of the right
capability
and everybody's happy and the advisor
saw the company being with them and they
just love the company wants to help so
this is the win-win that we can create
and we also have think tanks and other
vehicles that we created in order to
give us guidance and help the companies
moving forward incredible
i think then you know 20 minutes is not
nearly enough to capture the spirit of j
ventures and we didn't even talk about j
insights and the think tanks and j
philanthropy and the fel and the young
fellowship
it's really it really is it's a holistic
it's a community it's a community it's
like a
it's amazing and i it's it's been the
ride of my life and i've learned so much
and i really want to thank you for all
the opportunities that that you've given
me as a part of it you're amazing it's
been such an amazing part of it now i
want to go back a little bit to you a
few more questions going back in time a
little bit to your childhood what really
fascinates you as a kid you know middle
school high school you're walking down
the streets of jerusalem what really
fascinates other money
i always looked at how you can bridge
between
uh
people i i
growing up in jerusalem i noticed how
it's a secular kid i didn't know anyone
who's religious i didn't know any uh and
it's a it's a melting pot right
jerusalem is like
everybody is coming together but they're
very very separate and i said you can't
build a country when everybody is so
separate how can you bring them together
and for me it was
getting to know your neighbors getting
to know people that are coming
completely from a different background
so i had a religious girlfriend
completely on the other side of the
political map than i was
the first date i took her to
please now quarters because everybody i
knew was to my side and she thought it
was in kicamo
then she thought it's it's the
right-wing protest because it was
thereafter so we were
doing that kind of protest and then the
next day we went to help order so i was
in one where she said peace now and the
other way we say
all day all the country is out
i always try to bridge and that that
followed me all
over after and this is why java chooses
about bridging exactly and what inspires
you today or what is something that
inspired you recently
i i um
deaf people are inspiring for me um
i think uh i'm learning a lot from from
jim carson my partner i learned a lot
from laura lauder she's like the first
partner of j benches
um and and all the people who are
surrounding this i have so many mentors
and we'll find it give post league mark
abramovic it's it's just a long list i'm
learning a lot from you
um i'm all the time being inspired
that's the nice thing it's like
you're like in a candy store and you all
the time meet amazing people and you
just learn from them so the inspiration
is all over i think i'm just
i'm i'm fortunate enough to
not just say it really
to get
inspiration
on a daily basis from people
um and getting to know them
and
it's always a dialogue
you always learn and then
that's the nice thing it's not just
one side
and i love it so i'm being inspired all
the time there are lots of small events
and small and big people by sports um
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
i think i'm i'm a
i think i'm a visionary in a good way no
not in a in a ego way but i'm trying to
to think outside of the box according to
how the way i believe and according to
my value so the value is something very
important for me
and
i think i'm always
and this because of one of the
entrepreneurs who interviewed me and and
i realized that in every phase of my
life from being jewelers that i left a
very
a good position
in order to be journalist because of
of really mission the mission is
something that always
a mission which is usually social nation
this is whether i'm on the board of the
jewish federation i was born
i was i did wax in the heritage i was on
the board of jfcs um on
one of the founders of
the board and lots of i'm always trying
to
to find the balance between doing
something meaningful
and something um
business-oriented i don't believe justin
just doing something in the in the open
space without
a meaning i mean
makes perfect sense
thank you very very much
you